bien sûr il n'est pas encore là l'heure
du rendez-vous va pourtant être passé
dans cinq secondes 4 quoi
bonjour les honore les avait failli être
en retard peut-être les normes et mais
nous sommes juste l'heure ça va
asseyez-vous asseyons-nous alors les
honneurs ouais dis moi je t'ai fait
venir françois pourquoi tu me chante la
chanson
c'est vrai léonard ma chanson te plaît
ce set ferait plaisir est pour je ne
sais pas si elle me clé puisque je n'ai
jamais entendu et en plus je n'ai aucune
raison que te faire plaisir
excuse moi les normes et je comprends
pas très bien que tu veux quand même que
je ne chante plus la chanson c'est mon
affaire ne pose pas de question et
chante d'accord je vais chanter les
honneurs ouais écoute
[Musique]
créée savent c'est ce que je voudrais
l'infinie vrai
vous trouvez
être plein fouet les souris ont des vies
extraordinaires
je
explique ses mystères je voudrais être
très savante que d'être le secret des
choses à y être vraiment quelque part
des éléphants reese quelques actus
deviner ce qu'on trouve au delà des
étoiles il boite ont parfois des lions d
s'ils gagnent les moineaux les corbeaux
et les blanches tout près
les canes
[Musique]
là
brûler les dauphins les marsouins qui
sont de vrais maintenant
son
[Musique]
à londres
la mère je voudrais être très savants
connaître le secret des choses et y
at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants est ce quelqu'un est une
deviner ce coup trouve au delà des
épaules y voit trop parfois des lions
des hommes des segal
c'est ce que je voudrais
[Musique]
angers
c'est
la chanson tu as tu lu oui bonjour
au revoir
lennar excuse moi mais au revoir au
revoir bon on voit en voir les honneurs
et venez venez venez sinon les enfants
normaux ce renard est grincheuse au
revoir le nord voire voir
allons
monsieur du schnaps s'il vous plaît
monsieur du sna bonjour oui c'est moi
clé en a oui il faudrait que vous veniez
tout de suite me voir quoi évidemment
dans la maison de casimir ouais bon
dépêchez-vous 1 c'est grave ouais revoir
revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais ouais c'est moi
bonjour monsieur du snob des fichiers
vous signez vous alors que puis-je faire
pour vous mon cher ami huit mois vous
êtes bien l'homme le plus savant de
lille on vous faisait dans un homme de
ma qualité se doit de connaître tout ce
qui est important dans tous les domaines
la thématique philosophique artiste un
ça va vous êtes l'homme qu'il me faut
voilà ce qui se passe oui je vous écoute
franchement inquiète sur prouvant garçon
est très malheureux et je voudrais
l'aider
françois malheureux mais vous êtes sur
quoi je me suis jamais la percu moi j'ai
tout compris en écoutant sa chanson et
vous seul pouvez m'aider à le rendre
heureux avec eux très compliqué mais que
deux clubs à répondre à toutes les
questions que françois se posera sa
chanson comme cela il n'aura plus besoin
de chanter tout le temps je voudrais
être très savants vous allez donc me
dire on trouve des éléphants roses
l'effort
vous n'êtes pas si simple que cela enfin
vous allez pouvoir m'expliquer la vie
des fourmis
vous ne connaissez pas non plus la
réponse non avant un bravo vous savez au
moins pourquoi les dauphins qui sont de
vrais mammifères sont heureux comme des
poissons dans la mer
je suis désolé
mais c'est surtout moi qui suis désolé
je ne pourrais pas venir en aide à
françois quelle route n'est ce pas cher
à bouzy j'ai pas été incapable de vous
apprendre que
ce n'est pas venu grâce à vous monsieur
du snop j'ai au contraire après une
vérité très importante à bursa moins
vaguement essais avant de dire commence
et où il faut beaucoup mais beaucoup
travaillé
au
nord